okay let's go to our next color let's
try the 404 area code call her from 404
who's there hi David Jeff from Atlanta
how are you doing today good go ahead
Jeff
good I've been watching the news lately
and I heard the Republicans come out and
say that they haven't discovered any
evidence of Russian collusion and I was
reading in the USA Today today about
exactly how they came out and said there
was total attacked on our democracy from
Russian hacking now my question is is
this Russian hacking of the DMK they're
talking about that they are saying that
Russia hacked B&C stole the emails and
gave them the weekly leaks is that what
they're saying
it depends me I'm not talking about it
depends on your time in there's there's
a ton of different stuff going on so I
don't know specifically you're talking
about so I wouldn't be able to answer
you'd know more about that article than
I know about yeah I just I literally
just read it while I was waiting on hold
just now and and they were going on and
on and on and they still haven't been
able to be specific and exactly what
we're looking at because I've been
skeptical of the actual Russia mentally
since the beginning now I do believe
Trump is is in some corrupt dealings
with the Russian banks yeah and may have
done some illegal stuff before in the
campaign but yeah I'm still trying to
figure out exactly what and no one will
tell me exactly I can't find it anywhere
and that what is it you can't even joke
jump-jet hold on let's you're shot out
of a cannon today which I appreciate but
what is it you can't find tell me that I
can't find solid evidence like for
example people who do say the DNC was
hacked right that's been bumped debunked
by a gentleman by a name of William
petty who is over NSA operative oh boy
Jeff what would it take or what what
would it take to convince you about the
story like what would change your mind
and make you say you know what I think
there's something to it compelling
evidence what what would that be what
would you have to have some
where we can exist it would be a
situation to where everyone can accept
the evidence because it's just
undeniable so your standard of other
than that no one disagrees with it ever
that you would have you need a hundred
percent less on the I exist never gonna
happen and but they the stories come out
and then they get retracted more various
comments and then they just love the CNN
reporters who supposedly said that Trump
got a hold of Russian WikiLeaks before
they actually were released they went on
they went on about it for a couple of
days then it came back said oh we were
mistaken and they actually did not
receive them in advance and those three
journalists got fired well hold on a
second that whether whether Trump
personally received WikiLeaks documents
in advance of them being public aside
from that there's every indication that
the Trump campaign was in contact with
WikiLeaks and that WikiLeaks was in
contact with Russia and that there was a
cutout that's all been established and
the public timing of statements from
Trump and others coincide very
suspiciously with WikiLeaks releases so
look what what else would you need well
what you just stated right there is
great but it is an actual evidence it's
like right so on that may be evidence
what is the evidence that Trump would
come out and just admit it is that the
only thing that would convince you no
not at all if we actually let's say we
do a massage I said it was not a state
actor who came out and gave them the
information now Julian Assange would to
come out and say yeah well she gave us
the information and they hacked it then
I believe yeah but Jeff hold on a second
even that statement is worded very
carefully because every indication is
that there was an intermediary between
Russia and Julian Assange which gives
him the plausible deniability of saying
our contact was not an official involved
with the Russian government that's
completely consistent with what we know
about like there's no disagreement that
I'm hearing about the evidence it just
seems you don't like it oh I'm just I'm
just
wanting someone to the way that the way
the media is portrayed in this which
means as if they are the CNBC MSNBC CNN
ABC News everyone has accepted the fact
that Russia hacked the election I mean
as it right because at this point it's
basically undeniable given everything we
know that's not a conceit
I I guarantee you that all corporate
media would agree that one of the
elements that we breathe in on a daily
basis is oxygen the fact that they all
agree about that it doesn't make it
suspicious necessarily it might just
mean that it's the truth listen Jeff I I
don't think you and I are gonna get too
much further but I'd maybe re-examine
what you would accept as evidence and
check out our long-form piece by the way
30 minutes on the evidence so far it
might might find it interesting